[Música]
revista de prensa en directo américa de
france a 24 rosas pérez más deuda
conmigo en el estudio rosa abrimos esta
sección de revista de prensa el día de
hoy con lo que fue la noticia del día la
ilusión de ir en directo de una
productora del canal una de rusia
durante el noticiero con un cartel de
protesta por la guerra en ucrania
recordemos entonces rápidamente lo que
pasó porque sigue siendo noticia
efectivamente raúl buenos días a ti
también hablamos recordemos de mariah
opción y cova que irrumpió en directo en
el noticiero de la noche del lunes en el
canal 1 de noticias con un cartel en que
ponía no a la guerra rusos contra la
guerra no se crean esta propaganda
básicamente no recordemos acto seguido
después de esta acción de la productora
del canal 1 de noticias de rusia de este
canal estatal en la productora fue
detenida y él pasó unas horas en
paradero desconocido pero recordemos
también que justo después de esta acción
se empezó a compartir en redes sociales
un vídeo que ella misma había pregrabado
antes de llevar a cabo esta protesta en
el qué denunciaba pues la guerra de
ucrania y criticaba putin por empezar lo
que consideraba un conflicto fraticida y
llamaba a que está el quid de la
cuestión a los rusos a protestar
masivamente no contra la invasión rusa
de ucrania y aquí es donde vamos ahora y
la que es la noticia a día de hoy a ver
entonces vamos con el new york times the
gardian y el mayor ruso védomosti sobre
toda esta situación de la productora
rusa efectivamente lo que de lo que nos
enteramos hoy es de que ha sido
sancionada esta productora pero
particularmente por el vídeo que
decíamos que pregrado antes de irrumpir
en directo en el plató del noticiero y
ha sido sancionada precisamente por
llamar a una protesta no autorizada pues
por las autoridades rusas
la sanción finalmente ha sido de menos
de 300 dólares estadounidenses y de
hecho lo que se espera es que cuando sea
juzgada por la acción concreta de
irrumpir en los noticieros en directo
con este cartel ahí sí pueda afrontar
consecuencias digamos penales y de hecho
la agencia rusa de noticias ya ha
confirmado que está siendo investigada
por esta nueva ley que hemos comentado
aquí tantas veces aprobada recientemente
que persigue la difusión de noticias
falsas contra las fuerzas armadas rusas
con penas de hasta 15 años de prisión
por otro lado de garcía lo que destaca
es el comentario de un amigo de la
productora que señala que ella le
informó dos días antes de que pretendía
llevar a cabo esta acción sin embargo él
no lo llegaba a creer aún así informa
que la productora era muy consciente de
las consecuencias a las que se
enfrentaba y que la describe como una
persona muy valiente no cabe duda de eso
raúl recordemos que solamente por usar
la palabra guerra en lugar de operación
especial pues ya se puede meter uno en
importantes problemas y finalmente el
medio ruso védomosti
destacamos la descripción que hace de
los hechos es eso muy descriptiva sin
entrar tampoco en grandes valoraciones
lo que sí que destaca pues es
evidentemente que no comenta
habrá guerra sino que menciona esta
operación especial militar 'novaya
gazeta' rosa porque porque nóvaya gazeta
precisamente ayer destacaba como foto
del día la imagen de este momento no era
irrupción sin embargo ayer está chava y
digamos que borraba todas las frases
excepto la de no crean la propaganda y
hoy simplemente lo que borra es la
palabra guerra precisamente por lo que
mencionábamos antes y digamos quita la
palabra guerra de no a la guerra
detengan la guerra rusos contra la
guerra y en la columna que acompaña
digamos esta portada al excitar a soft
hace una crítica muy metafórica de la
propaganda mediática rusa de la que
forma parte según señala este columnista
cada alumno informa que bueno opina que
es una estructura que se está rompiendo
por dentro rosa vamos con un artículo
del país la guerra en ucrania también
apunta a los periodistas porque bueno
este artículo de raúl pues se concentra
como dices no en los cinco periodistas
que han muerto ya en estos veinte días
a este conflicto digamos en marcha y
este artículo está escrito a raíz
particularmente de la muerte de pierre
sacred y del cámara de la cadena
estadounidense fox news y de la fic ser
que acompañaba el equipo de fox news
alexandra q si no va digamos que estas
muertes se desencadenaron dos
conversaciones distintas por un lado que
el papel de los píxeles de estos
productores de campo muchas veces no se
valoriza no teniendo en cuenta que es
pues totalmente imprescindible que se
pone en riesgo a personas que son
ciudadanas del territorio donde van los
periodistas y que muchas veces estas
personas que corren digamos riesgos una
vez los periodistas y han vuelto seguros
a sus casas y por otro lado raúl hay que
hay que destacar también pues que muchos
jefes de medios de comunicación están
haciendo llamados a que los periodistas
no se aventuren pues a ir a la guerra
eso en busca de aventuras pero porque
pueden poner en riesgo a sí mismos y a
otras personas eso sí estos periodistas
tenían larga experiencia eso tampoco
es así rosa muchísimas gracias por toda
la información pasamos a saludar a
nuestro primer invitado el día